[Music]
inyoung hero news oh is this gonna be a
wholesome one yeah okay yeah like this
okay
submitted by Walker's of white oh it's
Amy and one month one month one more
month a boy saved a girl's life after a
snapchat suicide scare
how did he save her life this 12 year
old kid from Pittsburgh he had this
friend on snapchat his little girl
living in Texas
how old is little you don't tell me her
age but all right so she posted on
snapchat something about like something
along the lines of that she's not gonna
be here tomorrow she's gonna die and
then that's when Gabe told his parents
like hey like you know like this just
doesn't seem right like you know should
we check up on early there's this
checkup and sending dick pics to he is
not gonna be around
mom I think this is serious well so then
the parents we're like oh don't worry
about it like you know it's probably
she's just probably want some attention
and whatever is nothing really serious
so his parents told him to not worry
about it
but something just didn't feel right for
him so he faked senses said nope yeah
something's not right
he's 12 okay so they exactly told us
when it starts happening no I don't
wanna think about that
okay so then he contacted a suicide
prevention hotline and then they told
him to contact the sheriff's office near
her home and so he did and then that's
when they did a wellness check on the
girl and said like hey this is real but
so thank you so much for saying
something because luckily now she's okay
they would do the house and they found
something and he broke down the door
they didn't go into details they were
just saying that it was a real like
suicide scare and that luckily he said
something because then this led to him
saving her life so they didn't know
exactly how but he knew kids at the age
of 12 or thinking about killing
themselves yeah especially chicks social
media
brought up the suicide rate and
depression rate like crazy that's what
people thought I was crazy crazy no I
refuse to have my kids on social media
not just social media though like
everybody adults and children because of
social media and this powerful tool
there's been a spike in sadness yeah all
over the world it's that [ __ ]
comparison game when you live in your
own world you only have a small group of
people to compare yourselves to so like
it's just so I feel sad for kids because
we were experiencing it already
during our generation right so we had
MySpace me and also the [ __ ] yeah it was
already like that a little bit now it's
ten times worse [ __ ] that [ __ ] the only
person you have to compare yourself to
is your father
anyway [ __ ] and and you know the only
way we would get bad news is through the
news news if we decided to turn on the
TV yeah right but like it this will be
the same equivalent if we were talking
to our friends on like the phone and all
of a sudden there's a bad news
advertisement because if you're on
Twitter if you're on Instagram if you're
on Facebook anywhere you're at every
[ __ ] day something across your feed
will be like something bad [ __ ] happens
yeah dude I used to read the Twitter
Twitter News have all the time cuz that
sheet is spicy they update it all the
time Oh like I yeah but for real though
but then I started that ice like I ended
up deleting the Twitter app for a while
because every day they would try to get
you what the saddest news would be like
72 year old woman decapitates herself in
public I'm like god I recently had to
tweet out because every so you guys send
me a lot of articles and my Twitter and
on Instagram you guys Danny a lot of
stuff and it's always the saddest things
like the most tragic things ever and I'm
like guys please my heart can't take
this yeah admit it to the JK news
submission sheet like send me some
happier letters oh you know you know -
that's so like human nature we remember
threatening dangerous things more than
we remember happier things we're
inherently more negative we had takes a
lot of work to be more positive and the
reason for that is because you know it's
a survive it's a survival mechanism if
likes this is scary this is dangerous
this is
you're more attracted to it cuz you want
to remember so you don't get into that
situation or whatever right so the news
and
Media is just reacting toward people
that will that that they're just
reacting to the attention so it's not I
bet you that if people were attracted to
positivity and liked sharing that then
they would talk more about it because
that's what the dollars are at but it's
not the dollars in drama the dollars in
people oh my god this is crazy this is
what happened a natural disaster someone
died someone [ __ ] [ __ ] their sister
oh my god that's so true because even in
my position like trying to find articles
for us to talk about here there I'll go
to the subreddit I forgot what it's
called but it's about good news and I'm
always trying to find something positive
I'm like damn this just doesn't work
like we wouldn't you know but like I
really hope that like just the human
mindset starts to shift because like
we've noticed that like after Columbine
and after the news reported on that for
you know months there was a surge of
school shootings if [ __ ] happened
again last year and so people had to
come out and say like hey this is the
media's fault because y'all keep like
naming names and you keep making these
things public they make them infamous
you want the cliques and so they're
literally trading human lives for
cliques and in they're blaming guns and
then they're blaming parents and they're
blaming it's like well you give these
people you know Fame yes I was so sad
when that MIT kid no was a Virginia Tech
it was Korean I was like [ __ ] man
my Korean dude is [ __ ] with the actor
bro was like posing like he's a larper
dude you got bullied bull yeah forget so
the sheriff's office they sent Gabe a
letter and then some patches and I
showed you guys and then a little like
that's pretty so he is like really happy
about this obviously but then he also he
wants to work in law enforcement oh he's
older so then this is all like it means
a lot to him that's awesome so he and
then the parents are obviously really
proud of him and they said man I'm so
glad he didn't listen to us like I'm
glad that he actually went ahead and you
know student my personal like theory of
why people are depressed inside and
stuff like that to the
is reading has much more of a
psychological effect than someone
telling you something so for example
like if I were to tell you oh this is
what happened like drama those are car
accident down the street oh my god right
but that's me telling you when you read
it that's you telling yourself so when
you read but that's your voice that's
your inner voice
so when you read negative comments when
you read people talking [ __ ] when you
read all these things you're actually
saying that to yourself so if you say
you are such a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you
look like this
whatever whatever then your mind starts
believing it because you're saying those
things to yourself in your own work yeah
right right so your your brain doesn't
know that like is that your inner voice
saying it or you're reading what someone
else said Winnie the Pooh man that's why
you got to read that [ __ ] all the time
makes you feel look you need balance oh
yeah no eyein so I this was like
something I read about like forever ago
and I kind of drew my own conclusion
right but I was reading about how people
in like small villages or even people
back in like you know like like 1600
1700 in like foreign countries and stuff
they were there wasn't a lot of
depression and there wasn't a lot of
like suicide and you know by comparison
when you were raised and you're brought
into this family they're like hey you're
gonna be a textile worker this is your
job this is what the family does here's
somebody might marry here's this girl
and you're just like great this is my
life but in America we're told that
there's no ceiling like we have to keep
going up so like when you get born into
something and you're like hey this is
what you can be and this is what your
life's gonna be and you may you may like
check off all those boxes you're like
okay cool like this is this is right but
then in America it's like you could do
anything be anyone you can be famous you
can be rich you can be then never
satisfied
never satisfy like you're never good
enough because you're not achieving the
top celebrity level top billionaire
level or whatever and it's like as you
keep climbing you join a new ecosystem
and you compare yourself to the top
people in that ecosystem well once you
get to the top now you're in the next
session on you know it's kind of like
saying like how people that went through
what's the word like arranged marriages
like they didn't have to deal with so
many choices they just got in and they
made it work and they just dealt with it
and then they just kept on and some
people found love
and found that through their but some
people got like abused and [ __ ] up and
it's like but it's like how do you know
which is better like what's the better
method freedom or cut you know being
controlled and told what to do I don't
know
ignorance is bliss but I'm glad that I
know more but then when you know more
you get sadder yeah some movie you could
just have to be addicted to failure dude
that's my [ __ ] goal dude addicted to
failure I like feeling it feels good
it's okay I don't think people are okay
with failing you don't I mean so like
when you you could go ahead and have all
these [ __ ] options but you also have
to be okay that you're not [ __ ] good
at it and then move on to the knowledge
it's not only failure it's just
understanding that this is the urban
flow of life yeah do make basically
nothing's perfect you [ __ ] up you win
and you you just learn and you know I
think that's actually a lot harder for
people online because like I do I do
like failure because you learn and then
you move on but for some reason online
and your failures are public everyone
gets to see them everyone gets to judge
them and everyone gets to make fun of
you and you know your failure sometimes
becomes a little bit bigger of a blunder
then it should have been but those
aren't more awesome because I feel like
at least for my case my failures are
funnier fire right if I beat the [ __ ]
out of someone
I might get like five people like oh I'm
so good at party or so good
but if I got knocked the [ __ ] out and I
pulsed that people know that's like
crazy I brought so much joy to develop I
even more popular that's that's true if
people embrace their failures oh yeah
but a lot of people take themselves
seriously like we we kind of it works
with who we are right people expect us
to be clowns and [ __ ] like that but
there's a lot of people who don't want
to be a clown they want to be cool guy
they want to be yeah they wanted a
serious leader in the morning the more
you take yourself seriously I think the
harder it becomes delicious yeah yeah
you know what a good example of this is
fire festival we all got together we
made fun of these [ __ ] you're
like you scummy [ __ ] like blah
blah blah and then they came through and
they're like you know what I think we're
gonna do fire festival - yeah that's
funny
[Music]
[Music]